foreign
in Mill Valley California
hi my name's Ron I'm from Mill Valley
California and my question is about how
much money people have a feeling this is
going to have a lot of different
tangents but anyway I'm curious
so Ron is curious about how much money
is enough money but of course one
person's enough might be too much for
their neighbor and what is enough for my
neighbor may not be enough for me right
I'm going to give you a very simple
answer and then let's go into the
nuances because this is very nuanced the
simple answer is if you plan to retire
around 65 and you plan to live
approximately 25 to 30 years
a simple simple very simple answer would
be you should be able to live off four
percent per year of what you've got
okay so a million bucks in the bank
forty thousand dollars a year in income
now underneath that you can search for
the four percent rule to understand the
complexities of it and there's a lot of
variations but I find it aggravating
when someone asks a simple question they
just want a simple answer they don't
want to know all the theories so there
you go four percent like when I talk to
my mom and dad that's where we start
four percent okay so that's that's your
basic rule now what is enough okay let's
talk about it you know
many people they
retirement and older age is just an
abstraction and I hate that I I do I
want to take it from the clouds to the
street the street is where I can stand
it's where I can see people it's real
the clouds is just up here I don't like
to talk about that so the street means
what kind of Lifestyle do you have today
if you don't travel at all it's probably
unlikely you're gonna travel when you
get older if you don't eat super fancy
food or wear super fancy clothes you're
probably not going to do that when
you're older that's why I want people to
start living that rich life even a taste
of it today
uh often most people when they ask this
question it's in the back of their head
they just have this anxiety and fear
that says I don't have enough but when
you ask them what is enough
it's not really a dollar value yeah
right so they think it's a dollar value
I've told you the four percent rule
which is very simplistic but really it's
about knowing
am I going to run out of money which is
number one fear when people get above
the age of 50. it is knowing that what
kind of Lifestyle can I lead even if I'm
not going to lead it but I want the
ability to do it and it's just truly
being able to understand the mechanics
so if you are let's say getting older
and the market drops 10 what are you
going to do you're gonna freak out do
you understand the relationship between
your Investment Portfolio and your
returns most people don't and so when
you don't understand the basic language
of personal finance you let fear start
to speak loudly and I want to quiet the
fear voice it'll always be there that's
okay
but I want to enlarge the financially
fluent voice that helps people really
get strong enough to deal with these
existential questions did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free